Sorry. And uh thank you very much Tony
for the invitation and for the very nice
introduction. And thank you to everyone
uh for attending and and thank you to
the DDPM group for this invitation. It's
really an honor to be able to uh present
to you all today. What I'm going to talk
about today is really at the
intersection of um you know of ML and
pushing toward AI and uh physics based
modeling with what my group specializes
in is uncertainty quantification. And
you know we're going to talk about this
in some sort of broad brush strokes. So,
we're going to talk sort of big picture
about some things uh covering hopefully
covering
a a good swath of ground uh and and and
really zeroing in on certain uh certain
aspects of of what we do. So, you know,
trying to take a high level perspective
and zoom into particular things uh as
they as they're relevant. So uh to get
started um the first thing I want to do
is acknowledge you know a huge group a
huge team of of people who have
contributed to this work. So uh
everybody that you see on this screen
ranging from graduate students to
collaborators uh in various capacities
has contributed in some way shape or
form and to to the work that I'm going
to present here. Um and so I want to
acknowledge all of them. Uh many of you
for in in particular may be familiar
with uh Sumant who's down here at the
bottom middle uh who spent the summer at
at uh in the DDPM group um at Liverour.
So um
I'm going to talk about work that
everybody here did and and and really uh
want to emphasize that this is a team
effort. I want to start with uh a couple
I guess brief advertisements. Um as Tony
mentioned my group um oh sorry before
that I uh I have developed a course on
Corsera for uh uncertainty
quantification. So if if you're new to
uncertainty quantification and you want
to learn the basics, you know, this is a
good place to start. Um, for those of
you who already know UKQ and are
familiar with uh with the basics, uh
it's probably a little too uh
rudimentary, but for those of you who um
are interested in picking up the basics,
this is a good place to start. Uh and
also, as Tony mentioned, my group
develops the UQPI uh software package,
which is uncertainty quantification with
Python. Um the the thing I want to
emphasize here is that UKI is really
meant as a as a development environment.
So it's really you know we're seeking
we're seeking new developments. It's
fully modular and it's built in a way
that's intended to be easily extensible.
So new new things can be built in rel
relatively easily. Um and to that point
uh right now we have recently just uh
released the what we call the CML or
affectionately refer to it as Smile uh
the scientific machine learning module
which is built right on top of PyTorch.
So everything is fully compatible with
PyTorch uh Beijian layers and various
other things that you can do UKQ uh
right on top of PyTorch. Um so with that
with those advertisements I'll start to
kind of dig into uh the the
presentation.
Now I divide the presentation into two
pieces. Uh there's a very good there's a
very strong likelihood that we will not
get to the second piece. Um but I put it
here for completeness anyway. Uh you
know hoping that maybe if we have some
time we we can get there. But um part
one is going to be about talking about
how do we do uncertainty quantification
in scientific machine learning models or
as I'm going to call it UKQ4ML.
The second part is how how do we use ML
uh for UKQ purposes. So that's the
that's the idea of solving um solving
problems in UKQ with ML. So we'll we'll
come to that uh if we have time. But I'm
going to start with this UKQ for ML
component.
Um
so let's start very basic right so I
think we're all pretty familiar with
this idea of scientific machine learning
right we're at the intersection of
machine learning methods and how we can
apply those to solve phys for phys solve
physical systems usually in the context
of btees and and uh um maybe some
observational data um but that's sort of
the the the big picture and when we
think about uh CML we oftentimes think
of three three sort of classes of
problems right so we talk about PTE
solvers these are things like uh physics
informed neural networks and you know
deep gerkin methods and and and and
similar things uh there's PTE discovery
type of problems like Cindy symbolic
regression type of uh of problems and
then what I'm going to focus on
primarily today um is in the context of
operator learning right so we have an
unknown an operator, we want to be able
to uh we want to be able to to uh fit
that from some data perhaps impose uh
some physical constraints and and so on.
So when we think about operator
learning, you know, we're we're in this
context where we're starting with some
input function and we want to be able to
predict some output function. We want an
operator that's going to map from that
input function. Again, we're working in
function spaces to map an input function
to an output function. Uh simple example
of this is, you know, very simple uh
differential equation. You know, we
start with some some input function and
we're trying to predict uh the evolution
of that uh uh from that from that
initial condition. Um this hopefully is
pretty familiar to everyone, so I won't
belabor it. uh there are several sever
there are many many different methods uh
for for operator learning. I'll
highlight a couple that have been
particularly popular and and widely used
and and very uh very useful methods. Uh
in particular uh the deep operator
network or deep net which is built on
the universal approximation theorem
which really breaks the operator down
into two components uh both both learned
with neural networks. uh one being uh
the what are called the the trunk net
and the other being what's called the
branch net. And essentially what you're
doing is you're learning um a set of
basis functions that that span the space
of your output and the associated
coefficients uh for that basis uh with
the branch net. Um so again you
discretize your input um and you'd learn
a basis that's spanning the output
space. Um, another popular method that's
widely used and very uh um uh
works very nicely for many problems is
what's called the 4A neural operator. Um
and again in this in this method what
you're doing is you're trying to use for
transforms to approximate the integral
operator. Right? So um so that's uh so
these are two popular methods. Um, but I
wanna I want to sort of take a step back
from these because these are particular
methods that are really useful and and
widely employed. Um, but as we think
about sort of getting bigger and solving
bigger, larger, more complicated
problems, we're we're starting to move
toward what are widely known as
foundation models, right? So foundation
models um you know if we look at just
what Wikipedia says they're you know big
deep learning models that are trained on
vast data sets and they're expected to
work over a wide range of of use cases.
Um and I'm going to talk here about what
I'm going to call two basic classes of
foundation models. Right? So you have
your large language models which are
everybody knows and and probably uses on
a day-to-day basis. Now um but then
there's also so you have this the large
language models but then you also have
this emerging uh field of scientific
machine learning models or scientific
foundation models right so we're trying
to use very very large models trained on
vast data sets to solve uh to solve
physical problems um and this is really
an emerging an emerging area that the
DDPM group has done a lot of work in Um
and in fact you know the that I really
appreciate the work that the group has
done and saying hey we need you know we
need to set standards for this and we
need to um to really um build this whole
concept up because as it is right now or
as it has been it's been very loosely
defined right um and so trying to put uh
uh some some bounds on that and trying
to push that d that that that work
forward Um
it's sort of fortuitous that I'm giving
the presentation today because just a a
couple of days ago the nationalmy's
released this report on uh on foundation
models and one of the things that was
really highlighted in this report and it
I mean it permeates this report very
very uh very strongly is the need to
start thinking about uncertainty
quantification in foundation models. So
a couple of the uh conclusions that they
draw in this in this report is that VVUQ
methods VV being verification and
validation UQ being uncertainty
quantification um the methods that are
analogous to those for traditional
modeling don't exist in the context of
foundation models right those haven't
been they haven't been built yet um and
they need to be built and they need to
be and they're they're really critically
important um A second conclusion there
is that they need to be interpretable,
right? We need to understand what the
uncertainties and foundation models
mean. Um, and that's going to be
critical for establishing and
maintaining trust in these very very
large and generalizable models, right?
That that often times will look and feel
like black boxes. Um, and so their
conclusion there, their recommendation
is that the DOE really needs to take the
lead in this. And I think going back to
the to the paper here on the left hand
side of your screen, I think it's it's
uh it's really being demonstrated that
the DOE is taking the lead on this. Um
and and and it's really it's really
great to see. So um that's why I say
it's sort of fortuitous for me to be
giving this talk today because I'm going
to talk about UKQ and foundation models
or at least trying to nudge us in that
direction. Um, so when we think about
foundation models, uh, I want to break
down a couple of characteristics that we
think of with foundation models, right?
So we want generalizability.
Um, and I'm going to break this down in
the two types of of foundation models,
right? Your LLMs and then your
scientific uh, foundation models. So in
generalizability, right, LLMs need to be
able to do multitasking and CML. We want
them to be able to solve across
different re regimes of physics and
solve uh uh different PTEEs and so on.
Um we want them to be adaptable, right?
So in LLMs, we want to we want to be
able to span different domains that
we're uh that we're studying. In in CML,
we want to be able to span the
conditions that we're that this that the
problem can uh that sorry that the model
can work for different boundary
conditions, initial conditions,
geometries as I mentioned all across a
multifysics uh setting.
But beyond that, we really need them to
be extrapolatory,
right? We need them to work for tasks
that are that are unseen in the training
data. Um, so what that, you know, when I
think about that, I think about
scientific machine learning models being
able to be predictive and not
necessarily just predictive in the con
in the constraints of the of the
training set. Now, I will mention that
um these three characteristics differ
very slightly from uh what uh what the
DDPM group has called the core values of
generality, reusability, and
scalability. But I really think they're
largely consistent and I don't see them
as being at odds um really in any way.
Um so let's think about when the the
when I think about UQ for foundation
models, it's really important for me to
think about we have these very very
large uh very complicated models and we
need to really break them down because
in order to quantify uncertainty, we
need to understand the components of
those models. And so I'm going to talk
briefly about the components of
foundation models um as uh in the for
the context of UKQ. So we start with
some sort of um what I'm going to call
tokenization here. Um and tokenization
in the LLM community is very well
understood. But when I say tokenization
in in the CML
uh in the CML world, I'm really talking
mainly about discretization, right? We
have spatial discretization, we have
time discretization. we're discretizing
the problems that we're solving. Um, and
so those are those are somewhat
analogous between uh CML and large
language models.
And the next component is our learning
objectives, right? In LLM, we might be
trying to make, you know, word
predictions or sentence predictions. In
SCML, we're trying to do regression.
We're trying to predict in space and
time for uh uh for some operator or some
uh set of equations. And
given that objective, given the the
discretization we have, we have to
define a model architecture, right? LLMs
are largely based on transformers. You
know, you have encoder decoders, you
have decoder only models. Um, in CML,
it's sort of split. Some, you know, some
are transformer-based, many are neural
operator based, as I was talking before.
Um but there's no you know there's no
one unified sort of model that uh that
that's being used for uh for CML
foundation models and and the last piece
that I'm going to talk about is training
right so in training you have
pre-training phases you know where
you're churning through huge amounts of
data and then you have fine-tuning
phases right and and um in this is very
well known in in LLMs and in CML we have
combinations of different types of data
sources. We might have simulation data,
experimental data, um, and so on. And
those might come at different
resolutions and all these kind of
things. So you might be training on many
PTE and then trying to fine-tune for a
specific PTE or, you know, various other
ways of training. Um, the point in
bringing all of these up is that all of
these components introduce
uncertainties. There are uncertainties
in all of this and we need to address
the uncertainties in all of these
things. Um the second thing to to to
emphasize is that these models are are
huge. They're astronomically large.
Right? So if we look at some of the LLM
models, we're talking about model models
that have hundreds of millions to
billions of parameters.
Um in the CML models, you're you're
talking about the same thing, right?
Neural operator based models can be
millions, hundreds of millions of
parameters. Now, um, transformer-based
architectures again can be tens of tens
of millions to potentially billions of
parameters. Um, and a couple of models
in particular that we are we're
specifically looking at are uh the
neural combinatorial wavelet neural
operator developed by Soic Chucker Borty
and his team. Uh, so we're specifically
looking at that. I'm not going to talk
about results for either of these
models, but just letting you know that
these are some of the models that we're
looking at as well as the uh MPP AIT
model um out of the Flat Iron Institute
that uh has now I guess been superseded
by the the Walrus model, but it's a it's
a good transformer-based architecture
for us to kind of test out some of these
ideas that we're uh that that we're that
we're playing around with. So, now let's
talk about all of this in the sort of
context of UQ, right? So I mentioned the
components of of the model right? So um
we have uncertainty in all of the
components. If we think about mapping
using the model as a mapping from the
input to the output we have we have
uncertainty in the model architecture
itself. Right? What model is what model
architecture is appropriate? What
parameterization of that model is is is
right for the problem. That's a uh
there's a there's huge uncertainties in
that. Um, once we've decided what the
model should be, then how do we
introduce uncertainty in the parameters
themselves? And I'm actually going to
talk probably a good portion that'll be
the the thing that I talk about the most
here. And again, recognizing that we
have millions to billions of parameters
in in these models. Um, there's
uncertainty in how we quote unquote
tokenize, right? How do we discretise uh
the the inputs and the outputs and what
influence does that have on predictive
capability? You know, starting to push
toward things like multifidelity and
being able to train on data sources that
are heterogeneous from simulations and
experiments and so on. Um you have
uncertainty in your learning objectives.
So when you define your loss function,
you are defining a specific loss
function that is going to drive your
solution to uh to whatever you're
prioritizing. And so that in and of
itself introduces uncertainties and
those need to be addressed as well. Um
and finally in the training strategies
whether you're doing pre-training or
fine-tuning how you define uh how you
define and curate the data selection or
the the data set uh how you establish
learning rates and schedules and all of
these kind of things can be influential
in the uncertainties that uh that your
model predicts. So uh the point is that
there are uncertainties in every
component of these very very large
models and we need to address each and
each of those uncertainties in turn. And
and my personal sentiment on it is that
if we're thinking about models that are
this large and complex, it's really
essential that we break these models
down into these components and think
about how we tackle uncertainty in those
components uh as we as we progress.
Otherwise, you know, um we we get
overwhelmed by by the uncertainties and
and by the the sheer magnitude of the
the sheer scale of the of of the
problem. So the way that we've done this
is you can see we've formulated sort of
the the um probabilistic prediction. Um
so what I'm doing here is I'm saying you
know the probability of a prediction S
given some input and some data D. We can
express this in a law of total
probability that's sort of long and you
know ugly on the screen. But uh when I
when when we actually break this this
equation down, we can start to think
about each and every one of these
components. So if I look for example at
the parametric uncertainty, right? This
is the probability of my parameters
given the fact that I've selected a
model and a training strategy and so on
and so forth. um then I can formulate
this in a Bayian framework right I can
set up I can set this up in in terms of
B rule and I can say well okay I have a
likelihood function over the data and I
have some prior there's and and I can't
emphasize enough the importance of this
prior right there's a lot of work um in
particular uh work that's looking at
things like functional prior um and how
do you define priors that are meaningful
ful for physical problems. Um, and not
just, you know, declaring them sort of
ad hoc. Um, I'm not going to get into
that today. That's a that's a whole
another topic. But, uh, but it's
something that I I really want to make
sure to emphasize is important. Now, so
when we solve so when we when we set
this up using Baze rule, um, I want to
emphasize that also there, you know,
there have been some some works that
have started to do this in the large
language model community. There's things
like combining low rank approximations
with variational inference for LLMs and
you know these are these are starting to
um u to see the light of day and this
and very happy to see that these things
are uh are happening. Um
so let's talk a little bit about how we
then
define Beijian neural networks in this
context. Right? So we're we're thinking
about setting up and and learning the
parameters in a in a Bayian setting. So
we think of if I take that that one
component out of that long equation and
I simplify it. Um that's what I'm
showing here with B rule at the top. Um
I can set that up so that I can you know
I can I can calculate the predictive
probab the predictive probability of the
output um in in this way where my
objective now is I I've built sort of B
rule into my into my objective function.
Um when I do this the nice thing is that
I can apply uh you know law of total
variance and I can actually split the
uncertainties
um into an aliatory and epistemic
component. So when I'm making a basian
prediction with a neural network I can
see the component that's coming from the
aliatory uncertainty and this and the
portion that's that's coming from the
epistemic. Um, now there are a lot of
different sort of flavors of Beijian
neural networks and how we can think
about training Beijian neural networks.
And I'm not going to belabor all of
this. Um,
but uh there are different strategies,
right? There's more the sort of more
exact strategies where you start and try
to draw samples from the posterior using
markoffchain Monte Carlo methods um and
and and various uh other sampling
strategies.
um those are the most
accurate, the most, you know, the the
the ideal models, if you will, in some
sense, but they're also very very comp
computationally expensive and
prohibitive and struggle with really
highdimensional problems, especially if
we're talking about millions or billions
of parameters. Um there are of course
simplifications that we can make looking
at variational inference and and other
approximations. So in variational
inference we're going to assume a
simplified form of the uh of the
posterior and if we assume a simplified
form then we can minimize a a difference
between the underlying assumed form and
the true posterior. We can do this with
a various with a a variety of
divergences whether it's scale
divergence Jensen Shannon divergence
etc. um you know and this is a a pretty
efficient way of training bashian neural
networks but of course you're making
assumptions and of course you have uh
addition you have even uh even more you
know things like Monte Carlo dropout
where you're essentially applying a
Bernoli distribution over the parameters
and allowing yourself to randomly drop
out um as you as you proceed. So these
are you know they they get progressively
less expensive but also progressively
stronger assumptions that you're making
um as you move forward. Now if we talk
about being able to estimate the or
sorry uh sample directly from the
posterior one of the most common methods
is to use what's known as Hamiltonian
Monte Carlo. And in Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo, you define uh you define a
Hamiltonian and you know you assume that
the the position uh of that uh of that
system is the state of your system and
then you evolve that according to
Hamilton's you evolve the uh the state
of the system uh using Hamilton's
equations as shown here. you know, you
define a uh uh
uh potential energy as the log of your
of your distribution and then you can
evolve the system using numerical time
integration uh with a with a metropolis
Hastings acceptance criteria. uh this is
very very expensive to do if especially
if you're working in in high dimensions
because you're you're integrating a time
uh uh a time evolving differential
equation into your into your sampling
strategy. Uh so one thing that we we did
uh a few years ago to kind of accelerate
this is we said well okay we can take
that time evolving system we can learn a
physics informed neural network that's
going to evolve that system and we can
integrate that physics informed neural
network into the uh u into the HMC
process. So in in uh in this case what
we're doing is we're building what's
called a Hamiltonian neural network
where you use in graph gradients. You're
using autodiff to compute the the
derivatives that you need for the u
evolution of the Hamiltonian system and
then you're able to use your neural
network to evolve that system of
equations. Now this works nicely for
problems. It works really nicely for
lowdimensional problems. um and trying
to scale it up is where things is where
things get really really challenging. Um
so we've been able to scale it up to
problems that are maybe you know few
hundred dimensions but a few hundred
dimensions isn't going to get you
anywhere in a in a in a foundation
model. So um
so what we're trying to do is we're
trying to now take take these ideas and
say okay well how can we scale these
ideas right how can we get these ideas
to push forward to scaling to problems
that are going to be as large as the
foundation models. Um so I want to take
a step back just to look at uh you know
the different neural network types right
these Bayian neural network types right
we have Hamiltonian Monte Carlo as sort
of let's call it the gold standard to
some extent right so uh you can do
really nice things in terms of exact uh
getting exact sample sorry samples from
your exact posterior but it's really
really expensive now VI um you know is
really is much more efficient but uh you
are making some pretty strong
assumptions on what the form of the
posterior is and so there's questions
about uh how reliable your your
uncertainty estimates are and then Monte
Carlo dropout takes that even a step
further making stronger assumptions and
so um you know the question is how much
can you really rely on the uncertainties
that come out of uh of those methods. So
to test this out, you know, and think
about how can how far can we just push
the the methods out of out of the box,
we um we we ran a comparison here where
we're making a prediction. And this is
not a neural operator. This is not a
foundation model. This is just a
standard neural network. This a basian
unit where we're taking some input
microructure and we're trying to predict
the mean and the variation the mean and
the variance of the of the stress field
uh that evolves under unaxial tension
conditions. Um here our model varies
from you know 10 to 100,000 parameters.
So in the context it's you know it's a
decent size model but in the context of
a foundation model it's tiny right. Um
and so this is just taking those methods
out of the box and saying well what can
what can we do with those? Well in this
context we actually have shown that we
can apply Hamiltonian Monte Carlo. We
can we can run Hamiltonian Monte Carlo
up to that up to the scale of a problem
about this size. This is really where we
hit our computational limitations um is
when we get to these size problems. Uh
we ran that with the B compared against
the base by backrop algorithm. That's
the sort of benchmark method in many
ways for variational inference along
with Monte Carlo dropout. Um and what
you can see here um is that you have the
input microructure on the left. you have
a prediction of the mean stress sort of
in the middle and then you have um the
uh the variance of the of the stress
that comes out of that. And the the real
takeaway here is that while Hamilton
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo which is shown
here down on the bottom right um is sort
of as I mentioned like the gold standard
when we compare it against base by
backrop and Monte Carlo dropout what we
found is that there were significant
differences with Monte Carlo dropout but
base by backrop actually did a
reasonably decent job at recovering um
what came out of the Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo much much better so than uh than
the Monte Carlo dropout method. Um so
so moving forward, we're going to try to
we're going to try to leverage these two
methods, variational inference and
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo in some in in
some clever ways. Uh but before we do
that, so this was a paper that we
published uh in the last year just
looking at um uh these uncertainties and
and making this comparison. Um but when
we think about variational inference in
particular, so there's a lot of ass
there are a lot of different things that
you can do in variational inference to
compare the difference to compare your
uh your your assumed distribution to the
um to the true posterior. So based by
backrop as I mentioned uses KL
divergence. Another way is to use alpha
divergence or JS divergence. In this
work we used the um the alpha divergence
and one of the things that we highlight
here is you can see that this is a very
simple function um and what we're trying
to fit is we're trying to fit this uh
using based by back prop to get an
estimate of the uncertainty and you can
see that the the solution is very highly
dependent on the initialization how we
start the training for u for the for the
Beijian neural network. And so we
realize that this is sort of a
fundamental issue in the def in the
definition uh of the model. Uh and so
the way we address this is through a um
a s pseudoasian model averaging scheme.
So now we're talking about like
ensembles of models. So what we do is we
take we train several vi models. Um we
compute associated model weights from
each of those um using the expected log
pointwise predictive density. So you can
see here in this in this uh in this
array of of plots these are each
different models. So every one of these
has an associated weight. You can see
some of them are better, some of them
are are not as good, some of them have
high weight, some of them have low. And
then when you weigh all of these models
in uh uh together, what you see is that
you can recover something that is better
than the initial VI model but and is
closer to the to to what you would get
from the the Hamiltonian Monte Carlos.
So you get a better more diverse picture
of the uncertainties. Of course this
comes at the at the cost of having to do
ensembles which is of course another way
of of um of training the the neural
network. Um so up to this point right
we've talked about um we've talked about
how we can start to attack the question
of parameter uncertainty right so we can
do things like we can do variational
inference we can use alpha divergence as
we did in this work we can start to do
ensembles and model weights so now we're
starting to think about some of the
model form uncertainties if you're if
you're doing ensembles over multiple
models then you can start to attack
those things But we haven't really, you
know, we haven't really pushed anywhere
near the the foundation models at this
point, right? We're still working with
regular neural networks at this point.
Um, so that brought us to um, you know,
to really thinking about how do we scale
these these problems. So one of the one
of the hypotheses that we developed was
this idea and I think that this is
fairly you know um fairly common given
the application of things like low rank
approximations and so on is that not all
of the parameters in these huge models
are really going to be important for UKQ
purposes. Right? So when we have
hundreds of millions or billions of
parameters, not all of those mo not all
of those parameters are really going to
be uh critical for the uh for the for
UKQ purposes. So our idea was let's find
the most sensitive parameters, the ones
that are really influencing the
uncertainties in the prediction. And the
way we attack this is we we solve um or
sorry we we train the model initially
using variational inference. We rank the
parameters according to their
sensitivity scores. Uh we'll get into
how we do that. And then we're going to
take the the model parameters that are
very low sensitivity and we're going to
fix those parameters and then we're
going to apply Hamiltonian Monte Carlo
to uh a subset of parameters that we
think are the most influential.
Um so how do we define sensitivity?
Right? So we have a a huge parameter
space and in order to assign uh assign
sensitivities we have the ability to
very quickly evaluate gradients. Uh so
we do that using the uh build a tiller
series expansion apply the delta method
to get the variance of each of the
parameters um uh the variance associated
with each of the parameters I should say
and their total contribution to the
overall variance of the of the output.
And then we define a threshold and say
below this threshold we're going to
consider those parameters to be not
influential in the uncertainty estimate.
So if we look at again this you know
very simple sinosoidal model um
if we if we apply uh Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo on the right you can see that the
the estimates of uncertainty are are
fairly robust. You know, you can see if
we're doing interpolation, for example,
in this region near zero that the
uncertainties are encapsulating the the
true the true solution um with uh with
what you would expect to be relatively
high uncertainty given that you have a a
gap in that data. Um and if you compare
that with VI which does pretty poorly uh
in that in that predictive regime when
we apply uh the
when we apply the sensitivities and then
uh uh apply Hamiltonian Monte Carlo to
those sensitive parameters we push
ourselves toward the HMC solution. Now,
importantly, I should emphasize that
we're not getting back where we would be
if we could do uh the full HMC, but we
are improving substantially over over
variational inference. So, uh it's a
step in the right direction, but it's
not, you know, it doesn't fully get us
where we want to go. Now, we applied
this in the context of uh a Beijian
Depoton net for a um a hypersonic flow
problem. Here we have uh a number of
inputs represented through the energy
spectrum of the of the incoming flow.
Here we have 52 uh input parameters. Uh
and we're trying to make predictions at
four pressure sensors on on the wall of
this cone um the nose cone in the
hypersonic flow. So we're we have uh
four different sensors. we're trying to
predict the the pressure spectrum and we
applied this uh variational this vi
approach. Um this gives you a sense of
how how this method uh allows us to
scale u in in in a problem like this
like this depot. So if I look at the
number of parameters here on the x-axis
right what I can see is that the
uncertainties for 90% of uh sorry 90% of
the uncertainties are encapsulated by
only 840 parameters out of the
approximately 16,000 parameters that are
in our total model. So what that means
is that we can do a we can do HMC on a
parameter space of 840 rather than on a
parameter space of 16,000 which is a
substantial savings and allows us to do
HMC uh in a in in a much larger problem.
So we did this and you can compare uh
the VIHMC and the VI for this uh depotet
problem. It's a little hard to see from
these from these plots, but um the VIHMC
uncertainties are as we argue in the
paper are are significantly better
calibrated uh than just the VI
uncertainties uh for this for this
problem. And so that ability to reduce
the parameter space and focus
uncertainties on a small number of
parameters really allowed us to scale
this problem up to something again
16,000 parameters is not a foundation
model but it's it's at least pushing us
into into larger and larger problems. Uh
right now what we're working on is um
applying this in the context of a basian
fora neural operator. So in a basian for
f for neural operator what we have uh in
this particular setting is we're looking
at a six-story uh shear building
subjected to stochastic ground ground
acceleration uh with significant non
nonlinearity in the u um in the force
displacement relationship for the in the
floors. So the structure is modeled in
open seas. We have uh a number of
parameters again stochastic ground
ground motion um defined by a filtered
white noise uh stochastic process and
we've done this now just with a pure
neural operator and showed that the
forier neural operator uh performs
actually quite well for this problem u
in a recent paper. But now we want to
take this VHMC approach and we want to
be able to solve this with a Beijian
FNO. And so that's that's kind of a a
current uh a current work that we're
that we're working on right now is that
if you look at this uh this 4A neural
operator right now we have four four um
4A layers. We have about six million
parameters in this model. So, okay. So,
now we're getting to something that's,
you know, modestly large size, something
that's bigger than just the tens of
thousands of parameters that we've been
dealing with before. Um, but
importantly, the the the really
important thing that I want to highlight
here is down on the bottom right where
we can see that if we define our our
threshold, I think this is a 95%
threshold. we see that we can reduce
from 6 million parameters down to about
8,000 parameters in that model that are
capturing 95% of the uncertainty. Right?
So now we can do uncertainty
quantification on 8,000 dimensions
instead of 6 million dimensions. And
that is a huge savings. Right? So now we
can actually start thinking about
applying Hamiltonian, Monte Carlo or
similar strategies uh to problems that
are that are um uh getting larger in
scale. And so this is ongoing work. We
haven't uh we haven't finished this. Um
but I think there's a lot of promise
here that shows that we're starting to
be able to scale these methods to be
able to do uh uh UKQ in in larger and
larger problems. Um
the the the next thing I want to talk
about is this idea of being able to
incorporate that with some dimension
reduction. Right? We I talked about I
mentioned low rank approximations. Um a
big theme of my work over the past uh
decade or so has been combining
dimension reduction strategies with
surrogate modeling for UKQ purposes. So
in the sort of big picture uh you know
what we're trying to do is take a really
highdimensional input problem map it
down to something that's much lower
dimension and you can do many there are
many many different ways to do this. um
build sorry build the uh surrogate model
or the neural operator or whatever uh
you're trying to build in that
lowdimensional space and then lift that
back out um to to the to the
highdimensional solution. And um you
know so we published a paper a few years
ago that looked at a survey of these
sort of of dimension reduction schemes
using unsuper unsupervised learning
schemes to build uh surrogate models in
lowdimensional latent spaces. So we we
looked at several classes of methods
that um range from linear methods to
autoenccoders and uh uh spectral methods
and so on and we compared uh compared
many of them. So um this is just to give
you a sense of some of the things that
we've done in this space. I'm not going
to get into um into all into the
details. Um another another component of
what we've done is now taking that
dimension reduction here you can see if
I kind of follow this schematic through
here on the top left you have
highdimensional input that you're
mapping through some fun through some
operator fee onto a lowdimensional
latent space. Again, you're taking the
highdimensional output of it of that
system, mapping it to a lowdimensional
latent space. And here we're building a
polinomial chaos expansion surrogate.
These are what are known as manifold
PCEES. Um something that we've worked on
uh uh for several years now. Again, just
to give you a sense of some of the
things that we've done in in this space.
Um another uh another approach uses um
uh principal geodessic analysis looking
at how do we actually do interpolation
and and prediction on on manifolds. Um
and finally, you know, to the sort of to
the point uh uh of this of this work,
we've done this by building
neural operators in those latent spaces,
right? So you you make a a prediction uh
or sorry, you make you you project onto
a latent space or onto a manifold, you
build your operator on that space, and
then you project the solution back out.
So in this case, we're looking at a
depotonet. we we essentially bookend
that depotet with autoenccoders and then
you build the you build the depotet in
the in the latent space. Um, and the
reason I bring all of this up is because
now we can start to think about com
combining things like um using these
type of of embedding approaches to
minimize the uh to to optimize the
information content and minimize the
size of the networks that we need to
employ and then start thinking about
employing things like variational
inference with Hamiltonian Monte Carlo
to quantify uncertainty in these in
these systems. So, um, these are just
some results from I'm going to skip over
this. I want to get back to our our main
theme here.
Um, so going back to this idea of how we
can, um, start to approach foundation
models, you know, we've now talked about
different strategies that'll allow us to
attack the par the parameter uncertainty
and hoping to be able to scale to larger
and larger parameter um, spaces. Um, I
want to talk briefly about a couple
other aspects of this before I finish
up. Um, so I want to talk briefly about
this idea of uncertainty in the quote
unquote tokenization or discretization
in the in the case of uh scientific
machine learning models. Um so one you
know if you're familiar with operator
learning methods you you know that uh
that in many of these approaches you
need to have some fixed discretization
to your input or you need some way of
you know defining a uniform grid or some
sort of uh uh again fixed discretization
on the input. So what we want is to be
able to define this a neural operator
that is discretized on an arbitrary set
of points. We don't want to be
constrained by that uh by that fixed
discretization.
Now a neural you know traditional neural
operators are are great in that you can
you fix the input and then it can make
arbitrary predictions on the outputs. Um
instead what we want to be able to do is
we want to be able to make predictions
with um arbitrary discretization on the
inputs and arbitrary uh uh
discretization or uh arbitrary
prediction in space and time on the
outputs. And the way we achieve this is
through a projection. So what we do is
we take the input and we find an
embedding that is common uh for for all
of those inputs. we define a projection
onto that uh onto that uh um onto that
basis and then we use that projection as
the input into our into our our neural
operator. Um again not won't get into
the details of this if you're interested
you can see uh the the resolution
independent neural operator paper. We've
also done this uh with physics
constrained uh problems. So we have a
physics informed version of the of the
Rhino. And in this case again you have
input data that are coming from various
resolutions not fixed resolution. We
perform an embedding using a dictionary
learning scheme and then again build
this neural operator. Um but this time
what we're we're using physics informed
learning to to do this. Um this is a new
paper that we just uh just published in
the last several months. Um, so now I
bring this up because this is going to
be really important as we start to think
about how do we embed uh how do we embed
data for foundation models because you
need to have some consistency or some
sort of way of of merging data sets that
are going to be cons that are going to
be consistent in some way. So this this
idea of Rhino and similar ideas around
particularly extending this to
multifidelity schemes and being able to
extend this to concepts where we can
incorporate both computational data and
and experimental data is really going to
be critical in being able to understand
the influence of the discretization and
there the quote unquote tokenization on
um on these larger more complicated
models. So, I'm going to uh I'm going to
wrap it up here. I'm probably I'm not
going to talk about uh the second part
because I I I don't I don't really have
time to do that. But um I'm going to
wrap it up here by highlighting a few
things that we've we've talked about
here. So, when we think about breaking
down foundation models into their
components, we need to start thinking
about attacking each of those components
individually and thinking about
uncertainty in each of those components.
And what I hope I've I've I've
communicated in this presentation is
that we're not we're not there yet.
Absolutely not. I don't I wouldn't even
come close to claiming that we are. Um
but what I think we have is I think we
have some strategies that are allowing
us to start tackling this problem,
right? And this is uh and this is really
I think a critical problem for us moving
forward. So we've started to be able to
address parameter uncertainty. Can we
address parameter uncertainty in
billions of param in in billion
dimensional parameter spaces right now?
No, we can't. But we are pushing those
limits. We are pushing ourselves to the
point where we're getting closer. You
know, we're we're taking millions of
parameters and reducing it to thousands
of parameters that are influential and
quantifying uncertainty there. Um maybe
if we combine these things with
dimension reduction schemes with low
rank approximations then that can help
us to kind of continue to push that uh
uh to to the limit. Um
when it comes to model form uncertainty
as I mentioned at the very beginning
like these scientific foundation models
there's a lot of question about what the
appropriate architecture is what the
appropriate parameterization is and so
on. uh probabilistic ensembles might be
helpful in that. Uh of course they come
with a cost. They come with they come
with uh um uh they they come with
drawbacks but you know we've started to
explore probabilistic ensembles in the
context of of some larger models. Um and
then there's I think the an area where
there's a lot of really open challenges
is in this idea of of tokenization and
discretization dependence and how that
influences uncertainty. So I talked
briefly about some um multi-resolution
strategies that can maybe push us in the
right direction toward uh being able to
address uncertainties associated with
tokenization and and discretization.
uh in particular going again toward
multifidelity modeling and integrating
multimodal data um in in the foundation
model training. Um I will emphasize of
course that we have not addressed uh
several of these challenges right we've
uh we have not talked at all about UKQ
uh in the pre-training versus
fine-tuning stage you know many people
in the large language model uh uh
community will argue that well you don't
need UKQ and pre-training right UKQ and
pre-training is unnecessary because the
the the data sets that you're training
on are so vast and so large that you're
uh that you are
uh essentially negating the need for UKQ
at that stage and where UKQ is really
needed is in f is in fine-tuning
especially when you want to start uh
catering these models to specific
applications and things and I think
there's some you know there's some
justification in that argument but I
think it's I think the argument is
different in scientific foundation
models right um I don't think I don't
think that that necessarily that
argument necessarily holds uh in
scientific foundation models because we
don't have the entire internet to train
on, right? Um and so um I also haven't
talked about things like how we
understand the uncertainty in that
results from the definition of the loss
function and how we are prioritizing the
training of our model whether that
includes physical constraints and so on
and so forth. And so there are a lot of
components of this that we still are are
very very early and very very um uh
really have not gotten started on. Uh so
with that I am going to uh I'm going to
conclude. I'm going to go ahead and uh
skip to the end here. This is all the
stuff on um UQ for uh ML for UKQ methods
you know but I don't have time for that
today and I thank you all for uh for
joining me today and I'm very happy to
answer any questions that you have and
you know look forward to discussions of
this both today and you know long into
the future.
>> Yeah, thanks for the wonderful talk
Michael. Um so I don't see any questions
yet in the chat room but uh if the
audience have a question please feel
free to unmute yourself.
So as we give the audience a moment to
get their force I will jump in with a
question to kick things off. So I'm
curious about like in the VI HMC
approach you show show us some great
success of this um parameter reduction.
So I'm curious about could we always
assume I mean could we always see such a
reduction for for a guarantee do you
think the choice of the say the over
over parameterized model architecture or
the data richness or like some
properties of the physical system matter
to guarantee the uh decay of the
posterior
uh such that we can see a spar set of
sensitive parameters. Yeah, I think
that's a terrific question. Um, and I I
I suspect that it's going to be
dependent on all of those factors. Um,
you know, how highly overparameterized
your model is, how expansive and rich
the data set is, um, how it what is the
architecture of the model, right? All of
these all of these pieces that I've
talked about in this in this uh in this
presentation and kind of tried to
elaborate through that equation, I think
they all play a role here. Um so there
are going to be problems where a huge
dimension reduction is possible, but I
can also envision problems where the
savings isn't uh isn't nearly what we
would want it to be.
See,
so um are there more questions from the
audience?
Yeah. Uh I know questions may pop up
after hour after the session ends, but
um Oh, Jonas. Uh please.
>> Yes, of course. I had one question which
is actually about the whole purpose of
using surrogate models in the first
place, right? Because like they are
meant largely I mean there's a few
reasons, but one could be potentially
like memory or computational efficiency
in terms of training and these sorts of
things. Um my question is um
the methods you've been proposing right
like I mean I might have missed this
earlier but um I know the main issue is
there's often a trade-off between the
fact you might introduce a nice Yuki
method but if it is expensive enough to
train it kind of reduces the need to
have a circuit model in the first place
right because you have to add that and
maybe adding extra training for that
might sort of reduce the amount of
benefits in that case right so I was
curious like how much work like what's
the state of work with regards to
actually building more not just
efficient surrogates but like actually
UKQ that scales well with you know the
benefits of the surrogates.
>> Yeah. Um so let me let me maybe take a
step back and and maybe I I perhaps
didn't uh communicate this well enough
you know at the at the outset is that
you know when we when we make a
surrogate model um we are we are
introducing
a myriad of uncertainties that didn't
exist before. There were already
uncertainties in the problem to begin
with. we've introduced many more of
them. Um, and what we're hoping to be
able to do is without adding
that extra, you know, that huge
computational burden of additional
training, can we make those surrogate
models give you some estimate of what
the uncertainty is? So, you know, we're
still sort of operating in that in that
in that hope, for lack of a better way
of putting it, that the surrogate model
is still going to be a significant
computational savings. And so that's
really, you know, the that's really at
the at the heart of the issue is can you
make the surrogate model predict not
just but predict but predict with
uncertainty in a way that's still
computationally tractable and is going
to give you those savings that you
sought from developing a surrogate model
to begin with. Um
do I think we are there yet? Uh, not no
I mean certainly not in terms of being
able to do it with these very very large
models. I think in in in many settings
we we do a very nice job I think of this
um but not at the scale that that uh
that we would like to. I hope that
answers your question.
>> Yeah, definitely. Yeah. I mean it's more
just because like I mean I think a lot
of the methods you have here you've
you're talking about here are not like
as intrusive as a lot of existing UKQ
approaches, right? But um yeah, I've
noticed a lot of them, right? I guess
you sort of have this almost
multiplicative scaling with like adding
certain like extra training things, etc.
And so if it's something you can put as
much of like as an add-on that is not
intrusive, right, then that could
potentially be okay because then at
least it's like you kind of have two
separate things that you can you don't
have to heavily modify necessarily the
architecture to get that right.
>> Yeah, I mean certainly that's the hope.
Absolutely.
>> Okay. Thank you. Yeah. I know it's um
I'll definitely uh read more into this
and yeah I mean because yeah I was
working on a similar project which we
were working on a surrogate model where
we're like yeah we could introduce UKQ
but a lot of the pre-existing techniques
in that context would have um we would
have to totally change the training
architecture and everything. So
>> thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Sh I saw you raise your hand please ask
your question.
>> Okay. Uh hi uh Michael. So I have a few
comments if if I understand this
correctly. So you uh many rely on this
Htonian you know Monte Carlo. So that
basically you need to have a few
assumptions like your posterior has to
be very smooth and also you have to have
the gradient you have the global effect
and and also you know uh in practical in
practice you know there's some initial
weights and [snorts] the model being
stoastic you know there's uh tons of uh
issues there I mean uh and another thing
is I'm just thinking just some comments.
Maybe the other way I'm thinking is
instead of trying to sample um using the
this you know um different uh bion
methods and maybe you can also think
about make the uh assemble bigger you
know instead of like try to you know
using the uh combine the knowonial you
know Monte Carlo into the initial
assemble um then build a much better
prior knowledge then Another thing is if
you don't have a gradient in the um uh
in your uh bas network you might have to
use that trust region approach or some
like bian optimization to solve the
vision problem you know you know so
which is you know I'm just saying that
this kind of these things I like it you
know but it's just involve in practice
involve so many challenges you know even
you try to run this you know big um
a area model it can take very long just
just finish one wrong you know that you
know so that then can by itself can be
>> you know some trouble and greed can be
difficult and also uh assumption can be
very easy [clears throat] to be violated
you know just just something you know uh
I don't I I'd like to get some uh
remarks from you just so so I can think
about what should I do you know just get
some larger uh idea from you so much
yeah
>> uh thank you Shia Um the every one of
the points that you made is is a great
point. Um and so
I don't I don't in any way, shape or
form uh pretend to to say that this is a
uh you know a panacea for solving these
these types of problems. There are there
are a number of challenges uh that arise
in here. um especially I mean even
running our top chain Monte Carlo in you
know we're reducing in this example from
6 million to 8,000 parameters right so
running HMC in 6,000 parameter space is
immensely challenging right um and so
I'm not saying that HMC even is
necessarily the the answer um you know
there are many many different types of
uh of MCMC methods that could be applied
here um in this in this in this sort of
context and there are different ways
that you can approach it and all of them
are uh you know come with their
advantages and disadvantages. So
certainly recognized uh you know that uh
that aspect of it. Um
and
you know in terms of in terms of the uh
the the training strategies
there are
again you know there's just uh so many
ways to diff to to attack this and I
think that
what we're what we're aiming to do is
come up with techniques that are that
are viable to push uh to push those
limits and I think we're I think We're
starting to make progress in that. And
again, I don't mean to claim that uh
that we are that we have solved the
problem by any stretch of the
imagination.
Thank